[Applaudissements]
nous sommes dans 2120 dans 100 ans le
monde que nous avons connus touchera à
sa fin on avait résisté à la tentation
du nucléaire on avait repoussé les virus
biologique
on ne pense
et pas que l'intelligence artificielle
qu'on appelle et a porté par des robots
nous détruirait après avoir trouvé
les clés pour se déplacer pour se guérir
pour se ré
l'homme moderne l'homo sapiens sapiens
c'est augmenter en s'injectant des
nouvelles technologies des
nanotechnologies des biotechnologies et
cette fameuse intelligence artificielle
forte qui a fait de lui un super
dominant un post humain
on pensait nous les êtres n'ont augmenté
que ces post humain était l'ultime
menace alors on a imaginé des robots
aussi doté d'une intelligence
artificielle forte pour nous protéger
on n'a pas imaginé que ces robots
deviendrait si rapidement fort et
intelligent
on n'a pas non plus imaginer que ces
robots s'allierait au post humain pour
nous exterminer
ça fait peur non
il est rare lorsqu'on a une vision du
futur en matière d'intelligence
artificielle ont deux robots d'imaginer
des scénarios qui ne soient pas des
catastrophes pour l'humanité même dans
les films à grand succès comme
terminator que vous connaissez ça se
passe très mal
pour nous les humains et puis quand on
regarde du côté de la réalité
kasparov il ya de cela quelques années
battu par une intelligence artificielle
très récemment le champion du monde de
jeu de go kenji battu par une machine et
puis tout ce qu'on entend sur a6 robot
qui vont prendre le job il est vraiment
difficile de ne pas voir des frissons
lorsqu'on imagine le futur imaginé ça me
connaît un peu depuis l'âge de 4 ans je
suis un fan de super héros de comics de
barbaise le surfeur d'argent
spider man les x men et puis quelques
temps après luke skywalker dark vador
star wars et ce petit robot on ne repère
pas toujours toujours r2 d2 qui sait
faire plein de choses
moi quand je pense aux robots je me dis
que le futur est formidable on va
pouvoir faire des choses assez
incroyables
pourtant r2d2 ce n'est pas pour demain
birot bon et que de telles capacités
ça va prendre encore beaucoup de temps
pour arriver oui c'est vrai on peut
battre des humains au jeu d'échecs au
jeu de go finalement sur des domaines où
toutes les probabilités les mouvements
sont connus et où la puissance de calcul
des ordinateurs lors d'un avantage
décisif
mais at on déjà vu un robot descendre
les escaliers tenir des courses dans ses
mains donner la main son enfant tout en
évitant les autres croyez moi tout ça ce
n'est pas pour demain et pas simplement
parce que les technologies ne sont pas
prêtes mais aussi parce que la société
n'est pas prête
les lois ne sont pas prêtes la
régulation n'est pas prête
les politiques et les mentalités tout ça
ce n'est pas encore prêt
alors l'inventeur que je suis
il y a quelques années s'est dit moi
j'aimerais donner naissance à l'ancêtre
de r2d2 mais en utilisant ce que la
technologie permet actuellement
que dans les rêves faire du concret mais
aussi pour faire du bien aux gens et à
la planète et on en a bien besoin
vous savez tous les jours on pollue la
planète on brûle nos ressources
énergétiques
ce serait formidable que des robots qui
des capacités que nous n'avons pas
puissent nous venir en aide alors le
chercheur
l'inventeur et le fan de comics s'est
mis en action j'ai imaginé un robot qui
fonctionne qui est doté d'une
intelligence artificielle bio inspirée
ça veut dire qu'on arrco des des réseaux
de neurones artificiels mais qu'on
utilise aussi des fonctionnements des
parties du cerveau des petits mammifères
comme les petits rats par exemple vous
savez ces petits rats ils sont capables
de se déplacer de façon autonome sans
consommer beaucoup d'énergie sans que se
met beaucoup de ressources et le font
très bien mon robot
de même il s'appelle dit à one et j'ai
pensé que vous aimeriez le voir en
images
donc il est capable de se déplacer tout
seul de façon autonome il comprend
l'environnement il comprend les
environnements émergents que ce soit sur
des grands espaces que ce soit des
espaces où des gens assis recul grâce à
sa puissance et algorithmique et
regarder ce qui fait ça c'est une grosse
première mondiale il est capable
d'éviter les gens dans les espaces
dynamique où il ya des flux de personnes
ou même en tant qu'être humain a du mal
à passer et ils anticipent la venue de
personnes 1 grâce à ses technologies et
il est aussi capable de se recharger
tout seul il fonctionne 8 à 10 heures ce
qui lui permet de faire une journée de
service
et puis fondamentalement mon robot ce
qu'ils paient aussi c'est qu'il ya des
services qui sont vraiment utiles
alors il est capable de purifier l'air
intérieur tout en se déplaçant
il est capable de vous donner de
l'information sur la qualité de l'air
mais aussi sur le niveau sonore le
niveau lumineux est fondamentalement
aussi il peut parler avec les systèmes
technologiques comme la centrale d'air
pour réaliser d'énormes gains
énergétiques et puis enfin dia one il ya
une présence super amical les gens
l'aiment bien il fait pas peur
si enfin un robot qui s'occupe du
bien-être avec lequel on se sent bien il
ya de ça quelques temps un journal
scientifique très connu a fait un
article sur mon robot
je pensais qu'il parle
et uniquement de modèles d'architecturé
mais ils ont présenté mon robot à côté
de walle le robot de walt disney c'est
le robot qui prend soin de la planète et
qui ramassent les déchets le fan de
comics que je suis a trouvé ça vraiment
génial et je vous invite vraiment
regardant cette image d'avoir une pensée
positive en imaginant des robots qui
prennent soin de la planète qui prennent
soin des gens
finalement des robots écolo
plus fondamentalement mon robot incarne
porte des valeurs il n'a pas de bras
il n'a pas de jambes il est capable de
signaler en faisant des petits bruits
il n'a pas besoin de parler il a dix
jeux de lumière il fait des mouvements
d'autres sont partis dans l'industrie
avec des robots
mano ide qui ressemble à des armes à des
hommes
d'autres ont fait des robots animal aux
ide qui ressemble à des animaux j'étais
ravi d'apprendre que l'année dernière le
pdg d'une des plus grandes boîtes de
technologies a annoncé qu'ils arrêtaient
leur investissement dans ce type de
robot qui ressemblent à des armes
ça montre que lorsqu on exprime ce qu'on
ne veut pas on peut se faire entendre et
on peut infléchir le cours d'une
histoire qui paraît écrite et c'est ce
qu'on essaye de faire nous aussi au sein
de la chaire en robotique et éthiques
ali np grenoble l'ensimag où on invite
les chercheurs les industriels mais
aussi les personnes les citoyens à venir
participer à l'élaboration de ces robots
finalement l'intelligence artificielle
de mon robot lui sert à se déplacer pas
un coup d'éclat c est donc déjà en
compris que c'était important et se
mobilisent c'est une voix qui existe
d'autres seront là portée
le robot
c'est quelque chose mais il ya des
choses beaucoup plus importantes
la robotique va s'inviter dans nos vies
les jeunes vont avoir du temps pour
comprendre ce qu'est les robots une
intelligence artificielle
ils vont avoir du temps pour participer
à la création de ces objets de les
comprendre de connaître leurs limites de
connaître leur avantage mais ils seront
six comment les désactiver
lorsqu'il y en aura besoin ces jeunes
ont du temps stratégique pour penser
l'avenir pour apprendre et l'éducation
et la formation sont plus que jamais
nécessaires
on sait bien que lorsque les robots vont
prendre de l'importance dans nos
sociétés on mettre en place des
processus pour les contrôler mais aussi
pour vérifier ce que font les créateurs
les inventeurs les codeurs qui met de
l'intelligence artificielle et les gens
qui vont les activés pour les faire
rentrer dans notre quotidien
non
le futur ne sera pas plus dangereux avec
des robots
mais ils pourraient le devenir
si ça
êtres humains s'augmente commence à
acquérir un instinct de supériorité et
qu'ils regardent peut-être les êtres
humains n'ont augmenté que nous serons
avec un air de supériorité
peut-être comme les premiers hommes les
homo sapiens sapiens ont regardé l'homme
de néandertal
je suis ramesh et sans être sherlock
vous avez
compris à mon accent que j'étais
français mais avec des origines
indiennes
effectivement vous avez parfaitement
raison
je suis
et à l'île maurice au coeur de l'océan
indien une il sort de la réunion
et puis j'ai été élevé par ma grand mère
et puis après quelques années je suis
parti avec mes parents en france
s'adapter c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaît dans la famille dans la
diversité de mes valeurs
dans la 10
cité de mes cultures entre la france et
l'océan indien
on a su retenir des éléments forts
importance de la famille la science
l'optimisme l'importance de l'éducation
de la nature on remercie ce que le
seigneur nous donne les arbres la nature
remercie les bienfaits du ciel on
n'essaye pas de le remplacer
ces valeurs ont nourri ma conception de
la robotique
des robots pour l'environnement et pour
le bien-être mais c'est une pensée qui
grandit partout dans le monde
elle intéresse des chercheurs des
industriels partout sur les différents
continents mais aussi les personnes ça
montre que on peut avoir une vision pour
l'avenir
ça montre qu'on peut avoir une influence
sur le monde
même lorsqu'on vient d'une petite île
le futur a besoin de l'océan indien pour
se rééquilibrer de nos valeurs de nos
pensées le futur a aussi besoin de nos
enfants
c'est à nous de les rendre aptes à
vivent dans ce monde qui sera empreint
d'intelligence artificielle et de
robotique pour que les sommes que nous
sommes restent au coeur de la vie
[Applaudissements]